المزيد ينضم الينا من كياز
تيموفيلوفانوف مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
مرحبا بك سيد اييي تيفاني ما تقييمكم لما
حصل لهذا الاستهداف التي الذي تعرضت له
هذه البلده الحدوديه في بولندا
في هذه اللحظه الامور غير واضحه هنالك
شائعات تقول ان هناك انفجار لي جرار لكنه
وهناك اشاعه تقول انه كان صاروخ
وانه هنالك استهداف لصاروخ
اراضي
يكون انه في استفزاز متعمد من قبل روسيا
لاختبار رد الفعل اعتقده ان همم لم يكن
اه اه
قد هذا الامر يؤدي الى مساعده اكبر
لاوكرانيا وفرض عقوبات اقصى على روسيا
عن شائعات ولكن الرئيس الاوكرانيه يقول
انما جره وتصعيد كبير ويجب التحرك همم على
ماذا يستند الرئيس الاوكراني في التاكيد
ان ما حدث هو تصعيد تقف وراءه موسكو
بحسب رايه هو تصعيد بالتاكيد انا فقط اريد
ان نلتزم الحذر واذكر الاراء المختلفه هنا
يجب جمع المزيد من الادله لكن حسب رايي
الشخصي هو ممارسه مالوفه من روسيا حيث انه
يكون ذلك
انه خطا ويجب ان يكون هناك رد فعل حسب راي
الامر يعود لدول النايت دول الاتحاد قرار
حول نوعيه هذا رد الفعل لكن اوكرانيا
بالتاكيد تحتاج الى المزيد من الدعم
العسكري وخاصه في الدفاعات الجويه لكي
تكون قادره على اسقاطه مثل هذه الصواريخ
الاوكراني متاكد الى حد الدعوه الى التحرك
على ما هي المعلومات التي يستند اليها
خصوصا وان حتى الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول
انها ما زالت في صدد جمع المعلومات
وتقيمها
والله
اعتقد انني لكن اعتقد ان الرئيس الاوكراني
قد تلقى اجازا من الاستخبارات العسكريه
وايضا من نقطه انطلاقه الصاروخ ومساره انا
متاكد انه يديه معلومات حول مسار الصاروخ
واعتقد بالتالي قد لا يكون هذا الامر خطا
لكن هذا الدليل سيكون متوفرا لانه عاده
سيتم نشر مثل هذه المعلومات بعد ذلك
حتى الان ان تكون همم
استهدفت هذه المنطقه وتقول ان الصور تبين
ان الاسلحه ليست روسيه مع تعليقك على ذلك
اعدادات
فيها روسيا مثل هذه الادله حول استخدامهم
للاسلحه راينا هذا الامر يحصل في بدايه
الحرب وراينا ايضا مؤخرا في مساله رفع
الاعلام الخطا اعتقد ان هذا الامر يحصل
وفي كل مقابله مع وسائل الاعلام كان هنالك
ان كان من قبلي روسيا وبعد ذلك يتمت
اخطائها بعد ذلك
ادله ان هذا الصاروخ ربما بعد يوم او يوم
ستتكشفوا هذه الادله وان تاكد ان هذا
الصارو كان صاروخ الروسينا وسائل الاعلام
هولنديه
تحدثت عن سقوط صاروخين روسيين عن طريق
الخطا لو كان ذلك صحيحا لو حدث ذلك عن
طريق الخطا هل يبدل ذلك في شيء
هذا الامر حصل عن طريق الخطا اولا اعتقد
ان رد الحكومي والحكومات الاخرى سيكون لها
رده فعل انها اااا
تنتظروا الى ان تجمع الادله قد وبالتالي
تتخذوا قرارا في مساله التصعيد مع دمه
بالتالي هذا شيء همم حكيم ايضا الادله
ستتوضح لكن في اي حاله من الاحوال فان هذه
روسيا تقوم باستهداف في الاعراض الاخرى
النيه وهي في اماكن قريبه من الحدود
بالتالي تحرك وانتقل صاروخ عن طريق لا يتم
استخدام هذا الصاروخ ويجب ان يكون هنالك
اجراءات واضحه من اجل عدم استهداف في هذه
الصواريخ لاي مناطق مدنيه في اوكرانيا او
في بولندا او في اي اماكن اخرى
الامن القومي والدفاع من اجل التشاور حول
ما حدث هناك ايضا مواقف من لاتفيا من
مولدوفا ومن كثير من البلدان المجاوره كيف
تقراون كل هذا المشهد الى اين يمكن ان
يفضي
يتم استدعاء المزيد من الدفاعات وخل تعزيز
الدفاعات وخاصه الدفاعات الجويه همم
كلهم تحت هذا التهديد ويجب ان يحضر من
الصواريخ القادمه المستقبليه
ومنطقه باكملها يجب ان تكون متيقظه وتكون
متاهبه في دفاعاتها الجويه سوف مكان سقط
سقوط صاروخ حصل عن طريق الخطا ام لا يجب
ان يكون هنالك استعداد لاسقاط من هذه
الصواريخ وايضا حمايه السكان المدنيين
ماذا تتوقعون سيتموا في من دول النيته ومن
الولايات المتحده تحديدا
اعتقد انه سيكون هنالك الكثير من
الخطابات وان يكون هنالك ربما عقوبات
اضافيه ومساعدات عسكريه اضافيه الى
اوكرانيا وايضا قوات النيترو ستكون تم
وضعها في حاله تاهب القصوى وسيتم استدعاء
المزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه لكن اعتقد
ان الامور او رد الفعل سيختصره على هذه
الخطوات الاوكراني